lose control or I'm ready to roll and
I've been daydreaming
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm ready to read about this for a long
time
[Music]
good morning Linnaeus
for the last time this year this decade
see you next year see you next decade
happy Thursday everyone this is our
final show of the year very sad for you
guys I'm looking forward to a break I'm
not gonna lie I've never needed a
brachio so badly in my life I was slowly
learning that you brachio starts now my
brachio starts now to me it's a Friday
and I would feel sad for everyone
because this is our last show of the
year of the decade but we actually have
five more episodes coming out to you on
patreon starting tomorrow Claudia and I
have been working on them all week and
yesterday we went really deep we did an
episode of our personal decades and the
five past five biggest milestones of our
decades
I actually think tears were shed like I
saw CEO he was crying he was farting to
it yeah like his only actually gave like
an incredibly sincere and genuine
monologue about what it's like to be a
dog mom and I think that anyone who
listens to the episode will really
relate yeah it really was sincere and
genuine and it was it was quite
beautiful we learned a lot about
ourselves this decade we talked all
about I don't want I don't want some
wedding but we also have a bunch of
other episodes yes we did the top we did
the fast five stories of the decade I
think that she's the best ten because
yeah we did like all the pop culture
stories of the decade recapping those we
did another Facebook membership episode
and then we also did logistics part two
which is like more about our business
and how the toast toasts itself it's
just a robust slate of content one in
which I feel as though when you're
hiding from your family on Christmas
morning you will really enjoy I have to
just shake up my um iced coffee because
it's all at the bottom you see that yo
uh very gross very gross well I'm going
to Chicago right after this is just why
the show is early thank you for waking
up I really think you Jake thanks
everyone and thanks everyone watching
you know I'm heading to Chicago so I see
everyone three sold-out shows at the Vic
theater girls on job calm try get
tickets but yeah it's 6:30 a.m. Pacific
time like if we have any Pacific
coasters watching I like juggy thank you
literally no one's watching like for
sure right I definitely has to be one
early-bird on the pacific coast
yes
the Pacific Coast Academy yeah maybe
like they work no I guess if they do a
morning show then they would be they
don't watch the competition do you
remember like growing up all you wanted
to do was go to Pacific Coast Academy
course like so we went to one in her
convertible driving down Pacific Coast
Highway on her way to Pacific Coast
Academy yeah that was the life and then
you met kids who actually went to
boarding school they're like yeah it's
nothing legs that we 101 look because
typical boarding school like isn't pc i
like to me just cuz you went to boarding
school doesn't mean you went to pca like
unless you went to Pepperdine
you didn't go to PCA what's Pepperdine
Pepperdine is College it's in California
yeah it's where they filmed send it on
music video Disney friends for trains
Wow what it's beautiful beautiful song
we're and a beautiful campus and that's
PCA to me send it on on and on just once
Barnes okay we're both singing right
lyrics but second verses yes no one's
wrong in addition to all that we're
gonna do today we are going to recap the
trilogy that was Bravo last night
actually wasn't in the trilogy was three
and a half hours because we had the Real
Housewives of all what was first New
Jersey just Easter episode the saddest
episode ever then we had the Real
Housewives of Dallas finale then we had
the Real Housewives of Orange County
reunion part one then we had a housewife
from every franchise on the Block
drop-ins live and honestly by the end of
the night I was exhausted my weave was
exhausted my panty liner was exhausted
Leigh Ann loves a good period jelly you
know everything about me once I get my
period she just loves to like take
everything so far not even talking about
like her comments from last night's
episode which are just like she'd rather
live oh my god and then the way that
they I did an episode know the way that
they edited it to like show each
instance like I'm laying it all together
like that it like really was so
upsetting yeah as opposed to seeing it
over the course of three episodes and
she says it here and she says it there
but when it all comes together and it's
like wow she really said it so many
times in so many ways whoever edited
that episode last night was on fleek
with the flashbacks like even when she
was like oh I don't remember saying that
and then she owns it to Carrie she's
like yeah I said then they flashed back
to him ten minutes ago saying that she
didn't say yeah it was it was him easy
but no in general like her analogies
like the
on my panty liner is exhausted likes
extreme it's extreme
yeah so when we were capping that I'm
gonna have many thoughts about I think
of all the things that watch ass tonight
Dallas was the most interesting to me
mm-hmm
and also the women on watch shop inside
was fascinating even though they all
felt like they were super self-conscious
they couldn't stop looking at themselves
in the monitor like no one was looking
at it no one was looking at the camera
they were all looking you can always
tell when someone's like on the monitor
because if the camera is that here
they're looking here like it's always a
little bit below them and everyone was
just like looking at their legs and
honestly that's what I would do if I was
added much happens I've also but it was
like really distracting there was just
like no chemistry I said none so but it
was we got sneak peeks of certain things
I'm just Alex I thought they were gonna
show us a piece of everything they
should have okay I did go online and
vote because I really want to see Dallas
and we got nothing reason why Dallas won
is because we got a preview of next week
of Oh seen we got a preview of next week
of New Jersey we didn't get a preview of
next week of the first part of Dallas
Dallas ill and they gave us nothing
looked at one second between Cameron and
and Brandi like that was that's so
irrelevant at this point so irrelevant
okay well we'll get all into all of that
at the end of the show because today's
show it is the Fast Five stories that
you need to know this year before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast we are gonna be recapping
the Biela crunch sound that usual oh my
god sorry base you said it would
differently than usual you know I just
forgot it's gonna so I'm weirdly
recapping the top five stories of things
that you needed to know this here things
that shook us I'm assuming I don't know
haven't seen them I'm assuming you know
mysterious disappearance of Jeffrey
Epstein is on the earth of course and
just things that really shook us is he
heard we capping and now like taking it
taking a step back looking back in
hindsight like what did it mean you know
yeah honestly I was singing about it
while I put the list together and it's
like it didn't mean that much you know
you just think you'll see I I have five
stories obviously and then I'll have
like subset imb because there were a few
more than five things that I felt that
we needed to talk about I understand um
before I let you know what those things
were I feel like there's something you
wanna get off your chest you feel like
you're being burdened by something you
know what some things are just they're
better set in the song ready okay we got
that we got that attitude
today's episode is brought to you by
attitude if you want to get the best
sleep of your life you've got to try
attitude sheets they're super different
from other sheets
they're feathery soft I could attest
that seeing as how I've slept with them
now for a few months and they've truly
changed my life and also I'm housekeeper
coming up straight and she cleaned them
and then put them back on and like
honestly there's nothing that compares
to clean sheets especially when you eat
in your bed as frequently as I do like
you've got to wash your sheets and I
really don't know the the joy of fresh
sheets it's just the small joys in life
and a few cheats the joys are even
larger the best part about attitude at
least for me is that they have cooling
technology it's made of organic clean
bamboo it's extremely breathable and it
regulates your temperature to improve
your quality of sleep I talked about
once an episode of how I wake up with
this wedding act like all the time when
I'm sleeping but thanks to my other two
cheats I have a severely calmed down and
now I don't have like frizzy hair at the
back of my neck because it wasn't
sweating all night it's also
antimicrobial some customers have
claimed that their skin's appearance has
improved after switching to attitude
sheets read the reviews and see for
yourself also very true people don't
realize like not watching your sheets or
your towels like and then washing your
face with the towel or like sleeping on
dirty sheets can contribute to like
adult acne they're organic clean men
bill is recycles 98% of the water that
it uses so it's the most sustainable
bedding available cotton uses a ton of
pesticides and waste water and it's very
harmful on the environment if you want
to give the gift that a recipient will
love and future generations will thank
you for give the gift of attitude we got
that attitude
the amazing sheets have a 30-day
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your sheets for
a full refund
they even cover shipping on returns this
is bedding for the educated conscious
customer it's a hundred percent organic
attitude sheets their softest silikal
breathable as linen but at the price of
cotton you are that special someone you
buy them for are going to love them and
right now our listeners will get 20% off
their sheet set and free shipping just
text toast to six four zero zero zero
the only way to get the 20% off your set
of attitude sheets and the free shipping
is to text toast TOA st to six four zero
zero zero again
text TOA st to six four zero zero zero
sign on sleep amazing alright let's jump
right in what is the first story that
really shook us this decade the first
story in no particular order where's
your iPad I don't need my iPad why
because it's not like the it's not an
actual news story it's just like a
wreath up yeah so it's like we've we've
covered these stories you know the facts
it's just like your iPad looks so small
I just brought it just in case I needed
to research something but it's really
just a note on my phone today that's so
great
the first story no particular order
perhaps chronological but not even the
College Admission scandal in Rory of the
year very controversial and you know
what's so crazy and I'm sure this is the
case with a lot of the stories of the
year because they were the stories of
the year like it's still ongoing you
know well not for Felicity Huffman
actually she is she can sleep at night
knowing she paid her time for the crime
that she did and she can move on with
her life but like for many of the people
involved it is still an ongoing legal
issue and in an ongoing trial yes so we
don't have that many answers except for
Felicity Huffman I'm I'm very happy for
her know that I am that it's over for
her if you like so put this behind her
in this decade and move on to the next
decade and it really was the story of
the year but it was really to missive it
was such a controversial topic and I
feel like it's gonna be something that
is really spoken about at people's like
holiday dinners because so many people
are on different sides a bit like so
many people think it's like you know the
embodiment of privilege and it's you
know so wrong and then some people like
it's not that big of a deal fake my
parents do for their kids right and I
feel like I've been on the roller
coaster of emotions thinking like it is
a big deal it's not even deal like when
I first found out I'm like okay who
cares I thought rich people like always
bought their way into college I didn't
even realize it was illegal and then
like the more you learn about it like my
my opinion on it has developed over time
and I just know like I can see people
fighting about this did you watch the
SNL skit of people fighting at their
holiday dinners yes so funny really
funny I enjoyed it
good stuff yeah just like you know job
this is the epitome of justice is it
well um
hopefully can I do you ask right well
let's see off man I feel like justice
was I mean it was a slap on the wrist
but she what she did to pay the time I
don't think it was a slap on nurse I
think it was that was like the max like
she went to jail for two weeks for
getting her get into college well yeah
but if you like look at what other
people who aren't famous have like on
prison time for the same class I know
but it's better to slap on them I'm
saying judging it on its own not
comparing to other things just like oh
does the punishment fit the crime
for me yes but in the grand scheme of
the world like as it relates to people
who have like been sentenced to five
years for like doing something similar
it does seem unfair and like a slap on
the wrist but yeah I guess okay next up
speaking of justice justice Smollett oh
my god a couple that was this year yes
she's a Somali a the
piece of messy smollett really took the
world by storm this year let's let's
walk through it because what happened
was it was announced how was it an ass I
think he actually tweeted that he was
attacked or it was the police I keep
file a police rights becomes public
became such a big story like every
celebrity in the world was you know
wishing him well speaking out
he claimed that two two men yeah she say
they were white men yeah okay two white
men came and attacked him and said this
is Magra country and the poured acid on
him and put a noose around his neck and
like when we heard that like oh my god
like acid and noose that it's like some
biblical [ __ ] like that is so and it was
really pit inducing and I think it took
the world by storm in the way that it
did because the details were so specific
it's so horrible like who could even
join our Ville who could dream up
something so evil well I'll tell you who
had musty smell a because then and you
know what was so weird was like all the
details weren't adding up but nobody was
gonna be the first person to be like
low-key like I feel like this isn't true
because it was so terrible and if you
were wrong I ain't doubting him like
you're an [ __ ] 1,000% but was anybody
saying that even before there was
evidence any shred of evidence like no
one would hear that story and be like I
don't I don't I mean I truly don't
believe well if you listen to Dave
Chappelle special he didn't really
believe it because he said who good
Subway sandwich at 2:00 in the morning
in the winter in Chicago it's like
freezing you know so no okay but maybe
that could have meant he wasn't really
going to Subway like maybe that part was
wasn't true the best yes for the most
part everyone believed him I don't know
remember what it was that caused like
this spiral of people not believing him
but the security footage of two people
buying acid and a noose and they were
Nigerian then the fake check oh my god
that by the way of all the things like
that happen in the mousse a sommelier
case I would have to say the most
interesting and hilarious one is the
check it's like you're gonna be illegal
and you're putting it in writing
yeah like pay cash you're on a network
show go to the ATM bro and then also
like the police I would like the police
we're doing their jobs and they were
realizing that this story didn't really
right and you know that's like the whole
like the greatest the worse
thing that came out of this was like
though the waste of police time and
resources and that's what we were
talking about yesterday about like the
girl who like faked her Amber Alert um
like where is the punishment for that
you know and there should be there
should be but they they were building a
case against him and then like
mysteriously dropped out yeah
mysterious is how very mysterious very
just as mysterious as maybe um oh yeah
the the death of Jeffrey Epstein well
excuse me the death no no I think he's
dead some people could say he's not so
I'm just for safety the alleged death of
Jeffrey Epstein alleged death of Jeffrey
Epstein but also the whole year of
Jeffrey Epstein because first it was he
was being brought to justice like that
was such a great time we were so naive
oh my god we had everything was on the
horizon forever you know people were
gonna be taken down justice was going to
be served and then on one warm summer's
night a fell swoop one fell swoop it's
over it's over I cannot but I remember I
was drunk when I found out that Jeffrey
Epstein was murdered and I just remember
being so like enraged and like it's not
possible you know yeah it's like a dream
ya know it's like let's go back in time
but again I'm so proud of us as a
culture for not believing it you know
it's like and we're not letting you go
which I'm loving you there was actually
a breaking news in this story yesterday
was that the surveillance footage
outside Jeffrey Epstein cell that was
being used as evidence in some some
trial has mysteriously disappeared yes
the prosecutors claim they can no longer
find it
yeah from his suicide attempt his first
one ah the surveillance footage from
that so yes the story continues to
enrage America they keep trying to
pretend like we're dumb and I'm glad
that we're not letting this go and even
though I find the memes and the jokes
and the stupid fiction of pictures on
Instagram and the tweets so like really
start to like annoy me now like I've
seen this ornament didn't hang itself
like it's just it's not funny anymore
but we can't let the narrative stop so
I'm not angry about it I'm just like I'm
low-key subtly rolling my eyes but I
ain't yeah you don't have to keep
tagging me
every mean please stop stop tagging me
and memes and giveaways please what is
with the giveaways okay I know it's not
a story but this was the year of the
Instagram giveaways no it's it's out of
control and now what I've been doing is
anytime I get tags and they give away
and I'm silly enough to click on the tag
and then I scroll all the way up the
caption to see that it was initially a
giveaway I reply to the person who
tagged me with a question mark like
literally one person responded there oh
my god I'm so sorry I just wanted to win
that you were the first person I could
think of well that's sweet no and then I
was like okay girl let's win this but it
was in a way by the way and I can't even
look wait the best part is that of all
the giveaways I've been tagged in this
year I haven't won one right deeply
upset it seems like the odds are stacked
against me right like because you have
been in so many giveaways no no so many
giveaways and because I'm between
Instagram accounts every time I log into
club and then shop and say cumin tagging
in seventy five comments I'm like oh my
god I'm going by wrong no then like
these people must have seen my tic TOCs
no at Club with no job girl with no job
the morning shows Jackie O enter to win
this free and I'm always getting
potential we're gonna pull a Roy camera
or this ornament didn't hang itself or
it's like Target having a toasty water
bottle but you know what keep tagging me
in those actually really preciate it cuz
this couldn't smoke for our March 8th a
family doesn't okay our next story I'm
gonna do subset a and B because I know
the first part you don't want to talk
about and I just have to mention it oh
my god there's a Chloe interest in of
course and Jordan woods that was the
biggest [ __ ] story read table talk
that was and so that subset a of love
triangles
wait we also never spoke about how a
recent update to that story is that she
went on read table talk again and took a
polygraph test that is from the first
time she went on read table talk um but
they just released it for some reason
wow they did her dirty because she
looked so [ __ ] thirsty going back to
read table talk Wow if I were her I
would be actually upset at Jada
pinkett-smith
yeah and also like they weren't asking
the pertinent questions like nobody
thought that they had sex literally
never because in the timeline of things
there was no time for some no and that
was never the question the accusations
accusation was did you not tell Chloe
first before I came out on the news and
did you not even apologize to her ever
right and did you kiss him which you
said that you had done right for me it's
like that's all I need to know you
kissed your best friend's men sisters
man okay goodbye the most important what
the bug you know they really should
the master that they didn't ask and I
think is the most pertinent question was
their tongue that changes things yeah
and I feel as though there was tongue
but when she said to Jada pinkett-smith
it was really like a peck and you know
buddy pecks like in these days I like I
don't even pick my husband what's the
point right like honestly I don't even
pick Theo like we fully make out there's
a shadow band I don't care I'm proud
okay we don't need to spend that much
time talking about it because we already
and it was such a tumultuous time and we
also have other segments of this show
that aren't just the stories of the year
because like honestly they're the
stories of the year which means we've
talked about them to death which means
we really don't want to talk about them
anymore but we're just gonna recap it
for you so you know where we stand in 29
yeah well we have a lot of other things
to do we do um next up some happy news
Royal baby Archie oh really you is this
the fifth or fourth um this is the
fourth really I don't know if I would
consider this did they get married this
year no mm I don't know Oh royal baby
and when it's megan and harry's baby
that is big [ __ ] news and for some
reason we didn't like consider it big
news on this show like we talked about
it like we talked about any other story
just because it feels like we were
always talking about them but like be
and the name Archie's the best royal
name I've ever heard in my life whenever
I think Archie I know I think I should
think Riverdale but I think Shannon
beador snog I just think it's such a
cute name for her dog it is a cute name
for this beautiful golden retriever and
his name is Archie and you just like
lives this fabulous lies life in Newport
yeah and it's a great name for a royal
and it's a great name for your favorite
teen drama it's a great name for a royal
because I think his real name is
Archibald which is a great royal name
yes very historic but then he's like a
cool kid that's cool oh gee oh gee I'm
open throw me the ball yeah hey Archie
go [ __ ] yourself you know I love the
name Archie it's cute I mean you have
red hair like you actually should
consider Archie yeah to be the name for
a child I know but it's not like a
little too on-the-nose know like then
he's really like the comic book honestly
when you think of this is totally random
but when you think of like naming your
family and whatever like it really is a
branding thing of course then look at
Brandi Redmond and Bryan okay well I was
gonna take it to a higher level like
even she didn't realize what she was
doing my friend but like when she was
giving birth Kris Jenner was building a
brand and hearing her talk about how she
came up with the names Kendall and Kylie
on the most on the season finale was so
interesting because she was like you
don't just think like Oh Kylie Jenner is
a good name
Kelly Jenner she was singing of it as
Kendall and Kylie which ended up being a
huge brand like she was a [ __ ] genius
though years ago yeah and the way that
she not only like obviously gave all of
her names her kids names with K because
the last name was also K when it came to
him pretend her like you'd think she
would be over it no she was still
building a brand yeah and she continued
on with the case and then came with a
dynamic duo Kendall and Kylie like she
is just watching her just like subtly
explain how she like became a marketing
genius that she was like I think young
age just like being a young mom still
thinking of like the branding of it all
same with brandy Bruin Brian Brooklyn
and Broadway what's it what's a
well-behaved kids name who like wrinkly
brinkley yes that's actually really cute
actually I know we were gonna talk about
it in a minute but like that party was
so sweet that party was so sweet and I
know that like Brandi Redmond is no Kris
Jenner but like she's well on her way
she's well on her way to building a
brand of Brewin brinkley Brooklyn Brian
and brandy Brian Brooklyn Bridge brandy
Brian in Brooklyn Berkeley and Bruin no
no but you had to go toward our net no I
did
Brian brandi brooklyn ready brandy brian
brooklyn brinkley Bruin John right now
that great okay would you ever do that I
mean but you and Zach have totally
different no but I have some plans for
like a thematic situation for my kids
because you know I'm always in theme me
too I actually plan on having four kids
and regardless of their gender they're
gonna be winter spring summer involved I
bet there's a family out there of course
you know something funny one of my
friends going out for a chill everyone
in her family had names it started with
J and they just randomly named her
Rachel that's weird like Jenny Josh
Jessica Rachel weird yeah it's like you
were on track with the branding there's
so much that goes into it yeah and I
love when you really think about it from
like the from a marketing perspective
yes now I have to incorporate that into
my nameless yeah I have no idea
somatically I have a few thematic ideas
but then it's really limiting right and
then gender right you could have like
two boys and two girls names and then
come out with six girls right but these
days like gender gender is fluid and
gender names names are fluid that's true
you know like do you consider the name
Blake a boy or
could be either I can I know it's so
either what about Dylan
so either right Sam girl just because my
friend Sam is a girl yeah and what's a
full Samuel Taylor is a girl's name
yeah like besides for Taylor Lautner the
real Taylor Lautner okay are you ready
for a fizz and final and it's a subset a
and B we've oh I'm sorry I forgot subset
B first story three oh god okay it was
about love triangles and for me like I
know this probably doesn't rank it so
high for everyone I'm sure it does
actually but I feel like it really took
this show by storm let me think a love
triangle mm-hmm it not really love
trying I just was trying to position it
so it can be brought in a change n-no
what is it Tyler C Gigi Hadid
oh I agree that that is one of the
biggest stories of this lake that was
this rate that really shook me the most
to my core it made me question
everything that I thought that I knew
and that is a defining quality of a
story of the year and what was really so
impactful about it was that it was the
merging of many different themes worlds
networks and that's why it really was so
shook worthy because it was just
everything you thought you knew about
reality television celebrity Hollywood
models like was completely debunked yeah
it was just a crazy crazy time that
really was and it's so weird that like
we're not in that time anymore do you
know II mean yeah I miss it I really did
know I do too we didn't even know what
we had because we were so confused so I
think we really knew what we had and we
just like couldn't believe it was
happening it was too good to be true
yeah you know
so now I hope that Tyler seen Stassi
baby look gonna make sweet I didn't even
have time to ship them because I was so
busy like being confused and like kind
of hurt and then they broke up and just
in time for me to realize that I
actually do [ __ ] no just in time you
just got ready you know yeah you were
prepared my ship was coming in right
it's just it sucks when that happens
they then final story now by the way
this is the fifth and final story of the
year we'll never say this again in 2019
I hate when people like over the years
like okay this is my last bowl of cereal
for the year that's me oh I wonder what
I'm doing today oh that's what I do all
the time it's like I'm like this our
last night sleeping together in 2019
I'll sleep with you next year yeah oh
and they're like leaving but I'm gonna
leave here today I have it like favorite
see ya
decade yeah well this one this time it
means even more yes for sure didn't
final story our feuds of the year okay
well the first one Taylor Swift Scooter
Braun Wow and that really happened in
the latter half of the year machine it
shaped it it's causing you know tons of
conversations about musicians and
ownership and copyright an addition you
know what it means to be a woman in
music so thoughtful conversations being
had even though you know a feud is
what's like a seemingly simple you know
feud is what started it really
meaningful and impactful conversations
are being had in our culture yes I agree
and also everyone's got to take sides do
they yeah okay that's that's the making
of a best viewed by the that not even
pertaining to this issue but like just
that phrase everyone's got to take sides
those four words I can meet terribly
because that's we can't do that on the
show I don't take sides well you know it
and like even if we can take a side we
might in a few years like see it
differently and then just like we regret
everything that we said well thousand
percent and I don't want to ever be on
the wrong side of history and honestly
like there's a 50% chance any time you
take a side that you're gonna be on the
wrong side of history so if you never
take a side you're never on the wrong
side but if you never take a side like
are you for our purposes are you
interesting right it's like who wants to
watch a show about a bunch of people who
can't make a decision and Howard Stern's
book he says like the key to being a
great radio show host is to have really
firm opinions on everything doesn't
matter if you're right or wrong you just
gotta stick with those opinions look oh
my god any like what do you do the
opposite do the opposite but it seems to
be working
are we failures I don't know but I think
about that all the time it's like
doesn't matter what it is you just have
to ride it out [ __ ] no I'm in such a
bandwagon or it's like if I'm if I have
a feeling and I all I go it all in on my
feeling and like yell about this one
thing and then I turn out to be wrong
like i'm hopping off that ship and
they're getting on the right get one and
then i think about how all of my
favorite current housewives are people
who at one point were my least favorite
like I was literally signing history you
got them off jury
Cameron Wescott yeah Kelly Dodd yep
Margot Joseph's yep yes oh my god you're
right those are my favorite housewives
right now right and so when I look back
on some like the things that we'd used
to like recap even on the breath I like
don't even just agree with anything I
used to think yeah I'm like who are
these morons who in the show totally so
it's like why would I
now I'm now being considerate of my
future self I don't want her to look
back on me right now and be like that
[ __ ] was on the wrong side of the
Scooter Braun Taylor strip trauma like
yeah you know I mean even though I know
I'm on the right side but you know what
I mean
what's the side that you're on I'm
firmly like in the middle you know
leaning more towards Taylor Swift okay
and I'm I need oh sorry you know I'm
montello side like yeah I am
I believe her yeah and also she's your
girl so even if she's wrong like you
have to ride with your girl yeah for the
level of she girl that she is for you
like for me if Kim was in a feud and
even if like I thought she was wrong
amount inside I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
but then I also feel like that's really
like toxic Stan culture like even if you
don't agree with someone just like
blindly defending them and like
attacking people on Twitter who disagree
with you you can finally defend them and
not attack anyone that's so true you
know well ya know say that again you can
blindly defend someone even in a way
that might sell my demon healthy and you
don't have to attack anyone with your
blind defence someone make me a quote
card please like I literally put that on
my tombstone it's so true so you can
blindly defend Taylor Swift all you want
just don't come for people who might be
right about what they're saying about
her and you know what I feel like that's
very pertinent that we should just
briefly mention Camila Cabello like if
you want to like her Harmonizers or
whatever [ __ ] that's on Twitter and
it's like Frankie you want to defend
someone's indefensible actions like that
time you have to go tagging people who
were like offended by what she posted
you know right like but also it goes
both ways
ya know everyone can have an opinion
without like hating each other I know
that's like a foreign concept here in
2019 but like I'm firmly like that is my
resolution in 2019 or not even a
resolution because I feel like I do a
good job of that but my hope for 2019 is
that as a culture we can learn to have
more meaningful disagreements yes and
not just go below the belt it's very
real housewives like you could just to
me was someone without calling them a
pig face you know yeah also your mother
does I just want to say about being
blindly loyal like skin my dude I stand
K my ride-or-die I think she's so smart
and I agree with everything that she
does so she did something that I
personally disagree with it's like I
trust that she did the right thing for
herself
you know what I mean it's like maybe
from the way I'm seeing it it doesn't
look that way but like what I don't know
everything right and I trust all the
decisions that she makes otherwise so
I'm gonna trust this next one too I feel
like that is a very smart way of looking
at Stan culture but so much of
culture is like younger people who just
aren't at that level of maturity yet
yeah but I think sometimes they are
naivete is it's like ignorance is bliss
you know like you're they're just gonna
ride for their person and that's that's
just loyalty which is a good quality to
have as a human being not blind loyalty
though not blind because that's almost
like you can bring it back to housewives
like Cameron for the last two years has
been blindly loyal to Leanne she's been
loyal she's been loyal woman when Leanne
has been problematic like she hasn't
taken up for Leanne like in what when
she she have taken up against Leanne
butchers even acknowledging things that
she's doing wrong you know what I mean
but maybe she didn't think she was doing
something necessarily that wrong isn't
that blind loyalty
no she's agrees with her I don't think
Oh Cameron Wescott could agree with some
of the face Leon it look like she
doesn't agree with her and she's she's
letting her now maybe that wasn't the
greatest example but you know time thing
interesting okay and then the second
feud of the year was James Charles Tati
Westborough oh my god oh and I listened
to a majority when I was getting my
nails done of the podcast podcast with
Trisha Paytas and Jeffrey's our and it
was just so good
Jeffrey at one point like smokes a joint
and then really opens up like just about
everything in his life like about Nate
but he's like and he it's so crazy I was
so aware of like what people say about
him and he really doesn't let him bother
him cuz like even people I know who like
I know like on a personal level and I'm
like by the way like your jeffree star
san and they're like yeah and they just
like talk so much everyone like
apparently has something to say about
Nate about how he's gave her pay and
just like isn't with Jeffery for the
money and it's like like women and was
like DMing with people like to have sex
with girls and Jeffrey like was so open
about all that just being like of course
like it used to bother me but like it
bothers I'm sure it bothers Nate and
like he just knows like even the worst
things that people say about him and he
like doesn't let it bother him
whatsoever it's actually so crazy that's
crazy I want to listen to like what they
say about like people think airs but
it's like so vile like saying that your
boyfriend doesn't like you actually
likes women and is in it for the money
like even though like they've been
together for three years before Jeffery
was really that rich yeah but it's like
if things are good and your life is good
and you have a boyfriend that loves you
it's like who a it matters not at
not at all say that's true you know yeah
and and it sounds so like stupid but
like that at some point it is just
jealousy look you wouldn't be jealous of
Jeffrey star and it's also just like
this fascination like people are just
obsessed with like scandals I mean we do
the show every day like they it makes
the world go round
right um but people are just fascinated
with taking other people down even if
they're not actively like doing it and
writing the tweets they're just like oh
my god what does everyone saying like
right at the tea engaging yeah yeah it
was really good podcast episode I have
another 20 more minutes
I'm just really long well over an hour
oh I think I'll listen to it today
because I'm doing um ndo with my
favorite nephew yes nephew stay out now
if you stay out and I think I'm gonna
take him for a little mani-pedi whoo
he's very as long as the nail plates
like isn't super busy and there's like a
pedicure chair he can relax I'm like he
will sleep he's actually like we were
just talking about because it's the last
day of the year and someone was like to
bring Theo today I'm like oh no we're
just talking about how like when Theo
used to come to the show when he hasn't
been here in a while but like he's
really this year was also like I know
what kind of story like it was the year
of feel like maturing it really was like
from the beginning of the year and like
the way he was behaving on the show just
like kind of like cries for attention
you just like eating every piece of dirt
that like rolled his way right and now
he's just like he can't be bothered with
all of that you know he's so calm so
collected so cool like so everything
like it he's the boy he's the boy all
the girls want and all the boys wanna
make I think that he's like really just
found himself this year you know
motional ii spiritually but also
physically yes definitely okay James
Charles Tati Westbrook was the thing oh
yeah point where did we land I actually
landed in the very same place match I
was like boom boom Kentucky side okay no
[ __ ] invested and that's exactly what
Trisha Paytas said she was like scandals
are so weird because you always believe
the person that you're listening to it
because even with the Totti chain stuff
it's like everyone saw the talk to you
video I was like hotty totty unfollow
James unfollow James unfollow James
then James released his very compelling
video when everyone pretty much went
back to James and unfollow Tati so it's
like we never really decided where we
landed I feel like in the drama I really
landed on Team James the whole thing was
really weird and like a very
uncharacteristic thing for tot to you to
do and I totally like understood
everything she accused James of he had
an explanation for and like it didn't
seem like
it was excuses like I kind of understood
it and I understood like how someone
could get annoyed with the 16 year old
kid who got really famous had probably
became a little bit of an [ __ ] but
that's not a crime
like sorry I'm not gonna cancel you
because like your ass letting your
celebrity get to your head like you're
human that happens to everyone but and
it was such a big James Charles fan but
since that scandal I don't know if it
has anything to do with the scandal or
maybe I'm just like evolving in my
tastes like I'm just kind of over James
yeah so I don't know if that means I
didn't take his side because in the
scandal I did I believed him and I
didn't subscribe to toffee Anna actually
like in the whole scandal like I really
don't like talk to you like I actually
think what she did was like super lame
of her and like really immature and
started this whole like confered Yahveh
and then she liked to leave the video I
was like I didn't mean to do this but
like you did me to do it so like if
you're gonna do something stick with it
you know yeah I think it's like in
looking back I wasn't a fan of anyone I
didn't even really follow these people
until these videos and then I became
once James said his piece like I became
a big fan of his but then it's all about
what you do next and he took some time
off and then came back in like a kind of
not a smaller bit just in the same
business as usual sort of way and there
was just like nothing there was no next
next do you know what I mean
but what would there have been I don't
know just like uh I don't know because
they didn't do anything wrong so like
what would he have had to apologize for
apologize I'm not I don't I don't need
an apology but like what was what was
even his first video back to you there
was just a regular YouTube it wasn't
anything he's he's just been back to his
like same old content yeah I don't know
it's just like maybe cuz I never watched
it before when it you know I just was
only a part of the yeah I just like what
I like was involved and that's why when
he came for went talk to came for him
like I was fooling I talk to you side I
was like oh my god this little [ __ ]
and then he totally explained himself
and he took that break just because
there was so much going on and like
people talking about him but at the end
of the day you didn't need a break like
he didn't do anything wrong
yeah so the fact that he just came back
business as usual is what he should have
come back as he got attacked for
seemingly doing nothing for just being
like yeah a menace had a restaurant so I
think things are going well for him and
it's probably just because I didn't
watch his videos before that it's like
yeah but so that's kind of how I'm
feeling having watched Olivia Jade's
newest video uh-huh where it's like she
took a really
break as she needed to but now she's
back and it's institutional this video I
did and I didn't watch her stuff before
before the scandal really yeah I had
seen like one or two but I've seen her
so it's really for this video that she
just made this makeup tutorial isn't
like the same caliber of what she used
to do hmm um it's a little less it's
more simple I think she used to be way
more effervescent and like carefree on
her channel she is very much in her own
head now because when you go through
something so publicly like now every
time you say something you think of like
the different ways it can be interpreted
so she's definitely more reserved she's
not letting people in as much she like
she should take her camera all around
her house and her bathroom with your mom
or sister and now it's actually just sat
and straight did her makeup which wasn't
unusual for but her and maybe she'll
continue to do more in depth but I just
felt like she's there's definitely like
a wall up now yeah of things and things
she won't do things she won't say and
places she won't let us in yeah
physically and emotionally because she
can't she can't anyway so I don't even
want her to talk about the legal seven
she can't yeah legally she can't talk
about it and I also like don't want to
hear about it because it's like it's
it's kind of like with the the Jude Isis
it's like it's painful right but like I
don't know it feels like there's
something missing yeah it just feels
like she's changed and I think going
through something incredibly public will
change a person so this is the new
Olivia Jude got it
okay now before we get into recaps of TV
shows TV shows I want to go through the
top three toast moments of the year and
I will let you do that but not before
letting you know that the top three
toast moments of the year is brought to
you by best beans stars right an
explosive new puzzle game with snappy
and colorful graphics
Best Fiend stars is a casual game that
anyone can play but it's made for adults
you can spend as much time or as little
time as you like in the game the best
part of the game that you must know is
two important things
it doesn't require internet so if you're
on a plane you're on the subway you're
on a train you know you ran out of data
for the month you can still play Best
Fiend stars without it or not - the best
part is that it's free to download so
you know gotta go spending coin just
have a guess so pertinent to the
situation being able to play without
Wi-Fi it is a snappy quick and rewarding
experience you smash your way through
puzzles with super fun explosions and
collect tons of cute characters along
the way best fiends stars updates the
game monthly with new levels events and
so it never gets old best fiends start
streets the game like a service for
their players no internet required to
play so it is great for travelling
planes subway bored at work etc but if
you're bored at work watch atossa and
then play best fiends stars yeah they
have a fun little tool called boosters
it's like a mechanic that players can
collect to help beat levels you can
engage with other players by joining a
team where teammates help each other and
even compete against other teams you can
match them blast your way through
explosive puzzles and collect tons of
cute characters there's even a fun
social feature that allows you to team
up with friends or family
download best fiends stars for free on
the Apple Store today or Google Play so
again that's best fiends stars for free
on the Apple Store or Google Play check
it out and enjoy
maybe when you're avoiding your family
at Christmas you can just lock yourself
in the bathroom and play a game on your
phone Best Fiend stars for free Get
Connected okay top what was the thing Oh
top three toast moments of the year I
have them if you want to know what they
are
oh so you came up with them I did okay I
think that they're all-encompassing
you know what I trust you sis that's
been that's what I've learned this year
it's just like never doubt Jackie and
because she's usually right about stuff
so or no and these are in our particular
order from from three two one three two
one okay third best moment of the toast
it's everything 2019 to 2020 so he
picked out 2019 okay we've been doing
the show for like nine months like we
were in a group okay yeah third best
moment was the exclusive performance of
toast that we received the day that the
song came out and the speaker died but
our spirits did not our spirits could
never die honestly and I if you're ever
feeling down or at least this works for
me like I just go back and watch that
video and like I'm different after
watching the video it kills me it kills
me was a funny thing we ever did it was
so last minute but like obviously we're
like obviously were gonna perform on our
own show and we it was just it was
brilliant like and I I loved everything
about that and like that is something I
will cherish for the rest of my and it's
like thank god this speaker died
otherwise what are we doing we're gonna
go to the whole song no not only that
it's like okay there's nothing funny or
interesting about this performance
anyone anymore like it was funny could
that we get it but like it's goodness
okay second best moment of the toast
this year the Jonas Brothers when they
came on our show oh my god I was like
Dennis yes oh my god Halloween is always
a staple here at the morning toast but
having three procedures gas
who are so handsome join us it's just
everything like that little clip of the
video that they did for us before we
went live that was really nice of them
to come all the way out to our studio
while they were on tour like they flew
the jad they learn to write outside and
just not only do they show up they post
a premium content on our Instagram and I
will forever be great like that video
makes me laugh every single issue and
it's like you have to spend the video
watching a different one of us every
time I think you truly are the funny
it's like with your little yellow head
like yeah it's so funny like all jokes
aside I love our Halloween episodes and
every year we do Halloween me come up
with an IGN I'm like damn it's not gonna
be as good as year before because
there's so much pressure and I'm sure
I'll feel that way next year too but we
started out with just like us doing each
other and to be honest I was like we
will never do anything as funny then we
did Kim and Kourtney and Kris and like
honestly was kind of like a like a basic
idea but we did it into not do it I just
thought it was too easy and it's like
not that funny yeah like everyone
dresses up as the car - right but I
think a we all looked really good as the
Kardashians that'd be like the
role-playing and there was that was such
a hot time for Kardashian's who's like
the lunatik episodes like Kourtney and
Kim were fighting so much and we were
Kourtney and Kim it was perfect - it
really what brought it home was the Kris
can of course Kris snitch Jenner and
then this year I was like yeah okay I
thought we couldn't top left her I
thought we couldn't top the year before
so I we definitely can't top it this
year and Jonas Brothers was just so
funny and so pertinent and they also
have like an interesting dynamic that we
got to play on when we were being like
role playing and it was just it was
excellent I love Halloween I love
Halloween if you ever want to laugh also
go watch a video my favorite person
watches Margo because knowing she was
sick drop throat she was illegible her
being sick like made her more Kevin
because quiet yeah it was just so cute
okay in the number one toast moment of
the year can we get them to arm roll
from you closed on Sunday yes oh my god
to musical performances in our top three
and maybe I'm thinking we should perform
musically more often I agree and I chose
closed on Sundays number one because it
was an iconic moment like we brought a
piano to our show
snitch like played the claps yep and you
sung an unreleased Kanye West song and
like what no it also goes to act that
like Kanye
without you sheet music for a song that
hadn't been released yet like ASA
craziest thing of all time no literally
there's so many parts of it that are so
epic I think what we ended up creating
content wise was brilliant and great for
views and tons of clicks but the meaning
behind it like the fact that we got
reached out to by someone with an email
account at UC comm right I just I don't
know if I will ever get over that like
the recognition is truly gift enough and
then also the sneakers were a great gift
also right and also they had sent this
song take a few different people like I
saw Charlie puth I saw that too they
sent some of the songs on the album
everyone got a different song like the
fact that we got close on Sunday which
is one of the more iconic songs from the
album and is gonna it was like the
biggest moment on the internet like when
people their album released everyone was
like chick-fil-a and then he also is
only song he released a music video for
it was an important like not only did he
give us one of his songs like he gave us
the biggest song like and bigger than
Charlie puth crazy crazy should be uh no
more living for the culture we nobody
slave I'm on like a high falsetto look
in the toy box have a show tonight like
I can't be like busting my vocal cords
and the fact that we only had this sheet
music which tells you how the tune goes
but that we pretty much got it right no
that was the other say music theory
thank you mrs. Lee for those torturous
music theory classes that we have to do
steps to fit sit there on Sundays once a
week because we were closed on Sundays
yes exactly well what a great year for
us like those are three moments like I
can be proud of
yeah it's been a really great year for
the toast I'm so excited for next year
for the toast
like there's so and I hate when people
announce special projects and we're not
gonna announce special projects but
there is just like so much in store for
everyone look even when we come back but
you are just gonna be you're not gonna
believe like how much we've changed you
know yeah I think
it's gonna be our best area it's gonna
be our best year yet and we just like
love the twisters and everyone who
listens to the podcast etc and the
people watch on YouTube every day and
like pop off in these comments like you
guys are just the best and like we love
we love the toast we love doing this and
we look forward to making it better and
better in the next year live in the
dream you guys live in at the
[ __ ] dream live in the dream
okay so then I also gave you a little
bit of homework you did because we're
not done recapping this year I wanted to
hear from you because I read some like
indieWIRE or I don't know what
publication it was where they were like
they had everyone in their office do
like the 50 best albums of the year okay
[ __ ] trash so I wanted to hear from
you what you thought what your top 5
songs of the year are and your chocolate
album I have my list as well okay you go
first
with songs okay my number one song of
the year was my number one plane on my
Spotify and I think it just like it
shaped my year and also I was realizing
so I was thinking back on my ear it got
me to spend like a lot more money this
year on concerts merch like know this
song seven rings by ariana grande oh
just like gave me some sort of tie the
tube and mentality that like I need to
go buy seven Cartier ring and like I say
it I like it I want it I got it um that
I song just like shaped my ear I'll it
was my number one song that I listened
to you and I think it's the most the
best song and it just like really made
me want to shop and I did and I need to
stop okay seven rings second song of the
year for me beer never broke my heart
I was some percent like the best country
song of the year perhaps in the decade
and I suffered serious neck injuries
because of it okay third song of the
year for me Old Town Road okay
it's obviously everyone's song of the
year um I [ __ ] love that song I love
the Mason Ramsey remix and the Diplo
remix and I just loved what it did for
for the country in the world yeah
forth random ass song but um I loved it
and whatever on a roll by Ashley oh how
about a row but you have to justify your
answers no it's like they're kind of
random and these weren't even the top
five that I played the most but I just
like I love this song I love that it
came from an episode of black mare it
gave us old-school Hannah Montana if
you're better than the songs that Miley
Cyrus was releasing at the time even
though these were supposed to be like
easy versions of songs you know what
it's like no cheesy the cheesier the
better you guys okay and my fit song
that I loved this year was even though
I'm leaving my Lou Combs because it just
got me in my feelings yeah I love Lou
Combs and it was it it was a great time
okay that's that those were really good
and you know what mine are similar I
think maybe I have one or two crossovers
so great and also like obviously my
number one song of life of my my decade
of my year of our community is toast by
Claudia gray or something but that goes
with that pain I would think it would be
unfair for me to put that song in with
other artists just because like I'm such
a supreme talent to like all these
people that I was in that is the song of
our of our century like I don't need to
address that but my the top five songs
come from my Spotify but also just like
the way that I felt this year the first
song is so random and I didn't even
realize how much I listened to it until
it was literally the number one on my
Spotify and I was like damn I don't even
like associate with this song but then
the more I listened to it like I just
think it's a the best most like funnily
written song ever but like also so
beautiful tequila again by brothers
Osbourne okay like your number one song
literally my number one song and I it's
obviously because I'm always in the mood
just to listen to it like it's it's
country but it's also like kind of
alternative and the lyrics are just like
so interesting how the whole time you
think he's talking about a girl but at
the end of the day he's talking about
how he's falling in love with tequila
again it's just and it's also like so me
then on an emotional side I the Lauren
[ __ ] song that took the world by storm
that's called um believe no use I am
lost when I am phone
yeah yeah what's it called I believe oh
I believe yeah yeah totally impacted me
in a positive way like I had boys and
then I found Lauren day go and like now
I listen to a lot of her music I'm just
saying she's a supreme talent then the
whole album really impacted me and II
Grammer's album but I don't know why I'm
like forgetting all the things just
signature I found cynicism I found
criticism I couldn't get caught up a
phoner and I have found the villain I've
got motherhood take beautiful I found
you I found you obviously bear never
broke my heart I love what that song did
like for my neck but also like what it
say for me and my sisters yeah I mean
like a bond yeah was was real oh [ __ ] I
forgot a song on my list look I [ __ ]
up and I'm gonna put it in play seven on
a row by Ashley Oh hallelujah night
smile and Co that was my song of the
year yeah it was not on my number one
you know what it's probably do listen to
it a lot I do but also I only want to
listen to it when I'm in like when I'm
having a Halloween sorry the Lauren
Tegel song is called you say oh okay
yeah yeah no and by the way the cool
thing about having a hallelujah night is
that it doesn't happen often so it's
actually makes a lot of sense that you
wouldn't have listened to hallelujah
nights a lot because it's a rare
occurrence yes it's like I can't just
listen to it every time I get ready in
the morning like that's not a [ __ ]
halleluiah night then the fifth and
final song for me is a song that wasn't
released this year but was re-released
by a different artist and it was Ariana
Grande's version of The Wizard and I
like I have watched a video on YouTube
so many [ __ ] times and then
when they release it on Spotify like
it's all I do I put it to talk of myself
singing it like online like I just think
I first of all I love that song and I
just love all the wicked soundtrack I
love Ariana Grande being her musical
theater self and her rendition is just
as amazing if not better than the
original so I absolutely adore that song
this year and it was in my top Spotify
absolutely adore and so we have one song
in common that makes it the toast song
of the year aside from toast and that's
beer ever broke my heart and I feel
really good about that know I could have
guessed that yes okay and now top five
albums of the year okay I'm gonna give
you mine my number one album of the Year
album that I listened to the most
according to Spotify and that I just
love everything about is naive by Andy
Grammer
oh I completely like that was my album
of the year if I were the president of
the grand
like that would win albumen Theor yep my
number 2 is a curveball but it's so
[ __ ] good and if you like country
even a little bit you need to be
listening to it wild blue part 1 by
Hunter Hayes Wow so do those such a good
album called you listen to it on the
plane and try not to cry
ok number 3 for me is Taylor Swift
leather Wow number 3 number 4 Jesus is
king Vikon yep actually don't know if I
put these in an order of importance and
number 5 is just came in at the last
minute Lady Antebellum ocean most
beautiful [ __ ] album of all time
ok that's really beautiful for me
obviously lover was my number 1 album
like the fact that we got 18 songs from
Taylor's trip this year like I'm good
for another like six months like I'm I'm
good and then the Christmas tree farm
which by the way the more I listen to I
realize is literally the best song ever
written did you see her perform it at
Jingle Ball Capital FM it's literally
the most it's better live ok I have to
check it out that's becoming my favorite
Taylor Swift song of all time Jackie the
bridge is so good with the court I mean
with the quarter it's like I don't have
any musical talent like nothing but it's
like if I did that's the song I would
write yeah and you would be there too
under the mistletoe it's so good I'm so
glad you like it
my second album of the year is bear
never broke my heart Lou comes like just
also 17 songs like living for a long
album thank you so much
the third is like a lesser known artist
and it's technically an EP it's toast by
Claudia ashtray like I started to throw
myself in there I mean I wasn't sure was
girl by Maren Morris releases here yeah
okay my fourth is girl by Maren Morris
it was one of the first albums that came
out this year so I was like the first
album this year that I got to like live
with and I just thought it was
incredible like so so diverse like I
don't even know if I would call it
conscious like no it's really cross
genre and it wasn't everyone loves it
like my friends who don't like country
music
love it right and that one's the one
song on there that I like love the most
obvious the most country is a collab
with the guy from brothers Osbourne all
my favorite people it's like that song
will never not make me just want to get
up and like spend all my money on my gas
and marijuana you know yeah and then my
fifth of the year uh-oh is um so random
but I actually like really like love
this album and I didn't really listen to
it so much when it came out but I've
just like slowly been listening to all
the songs and they're all kind of
bangers it's Tucker by Jonas Brothers
okay cool yeah good because that was on
a lot of top album of the year list yeah
and it's just like I never expected that
for myself but I really identified with
the music loved it
I also wouldn't give some honorable
mentions obviously lizzo was a huge
party she was on my list had a hard time
choosing just one song of hers you know
so that's why I didn't make it to my top
five also one of my favorite songs this
year was from song land yeah which one
young the Old Dominion yeah so check it
out if you haven't um that just makes me
want to go and listen to music but we
can't go do that because we need to
recap everything on Bravo last night
let's take it from the top because
you've got a flight to catch our recaps
are brought to you by sin bird did you
know that cent is the most powerful
sense you have a smell can bring on a
flood of memories influence your mood
and of course enhance your natural style
while you're looking for that signature
scent that will make you stand out and
keep the memory of you lingering on why
waste so much time and money with cheap
knockoffs and half-empty bottles of
failed experiments with scent bird you
can have great taste and mix up your
fragrance routine without breaking the
bank
whether it's Tom Ford Gucci or Versace
Sandberg comm keeps you smelling good
after month um I have personally tried a
Gucci perfume a mountain goats perfume a
tons of different perfumes because I've
now been subscribed for over a year
and I just really like mixing up my
fragrance routine trying ones I haven't
used before and also not spending a lot
of money in case I don't like love
something I love that said bird is a
luxury fragrance subscription service
for perfumes and colognes they have more
than 600 designer brands for you to
choose from every month
choose the perfume you want to try
they'll send you a 30-day supply if
you're not sure what type of scent
you're looking for you can sort and find
new fragrances by brand style occassions
season and more plus they have products
from other categories like skincare
wellness and makeup they carry brands
like Coke poori which is a favorite here
at the morning totes glam glow and glow
recipe we have an exclusive offer for
our listeners you can get 30% off in the
first month today that's only ten
dollars for your first fragrance go to
scent bird comm slash steen our offer
has change so make sure you're listening
scent bird comm slash teen or use the
code Steen for your first month 30% off
again that's SCE MTBI Rd comm / Steen or
you can just use the code ste and for
your first perfumer cologne for just $10
for the last time this year ok Bravo
recap first we started with the Easter
episode of New Jersey which was
incredibly sad and incredibly separate I
don't remember a recent episode of
housewives where everyone was like no
one was together I don't suppose we went
from Jamaica to back home into the
holidays yeah we were just fragmented I
didn't mind good did you cry of course
one no no started at 12:30 crying about
how could how could anyone not know I
really don't think there was a dry eye
in the country started crying when
Teresa was saying grace and addressing
his wife there her ground oh my god it
just set me off except like I I went no
no it's such a roller coaster of emotion
because him drinking the hot sauce from
the fridge when he started drinking I'm
like damn that looks like hot sauce and
then they zoomed in as I guess it is in
fact hot sauce so funny
and then he goes through weakness laughs
to making us cry like I just I like when
I you know lay my head on my pillow at
night and I pray for things like I pray
for health and wellness for no no
because like he's such an important
figure in the family and he's finally
now alive to see his family getting
along so beautifully that's also why I
was crying it's like these people have
been through like the worst of the worst
in the most public ways and it's so
terrible that it took like this tragedy
like to bring them together but like now
it's like they're thick as thieves like
nothing could ever tear them apart
listen the way like Joey Gorga has like
stepped up for these kids like I
couldn't stop crying like when he got on
the phone with Joe and he was crying
like he is such a role model for like
all the kids in the family and he's
really like stepped up and he's there
every day taking them to school cooking
like he does everything in like I just
like Stan Joey Gorga to the highest
degree to the highest degree like a nice
and Melissa and Joe and they're just
doing everything right also like seeing
Antonia and her cousins like they're
literally all sisters it's the sweetest
thing I was crying it was it was just
like too it was too much and Joe I mean
we know eventually he goes back to Italy
like he needs to if I can go he'd sit
out of that that ice and I don't know if
and I'm not a mom and it's not my
business but I don't know if Teresa not
telling Audriana was the right move
because kids know stuff and like she's
talking about it right in front of her
like she knows yeah and it's I guess
she's tall for her age cuz she feels a
lot older than there is reading her also
she looks like Gabriella yeah and I get
them confused because they're twins Gian
Milania are spitting images of each
other and Milania and Audriana and
Gabriella are twins yeah it's crazy it
is crazy but they're really such an
amazing family and again gia just being
like the pinnacle of strength always but
always pinnacle strength but also like
so sensitive emotional and in touch with
her feelings but only around her mom
should only have been younger simpler
also so in control everyone else's
Thanksgivings were pretty much
irrelevant because nothing's giving
Easter we're irrelevant because like I
care that I thought the big conversation
was gonna be like Dolores David and
Frank and it's like I wasn't even paying
attention cuz I was wiping my tears away
um obviously hold on I actually wrote
down notes from last night's cuz there
was so much oh I did not know that
Jennifer had a brother who was gay and I
thought she handled that conversation
very well because it's obviously like a
tumultuous thing in their family seeing
as how the mom won't even address the
fact that her son is gay and I thought
it was really cool how she handled the
question like her daughter was just like
mom is uncle whatever his name is gay
and she's like yeah yeah matter like I
just thought like I can't wait they
captured that moment on television
because it's obviously the first time
that she ever noticed that he might be
gay and it's like not a big deal and I
thought it was so cute I was teaching
them piano lessons and how musical
theater was like his save space growing
up and I just like every day like Stan
Jennifer more and more no we haven't no
we have no choice even if I had a choice
which we don't which we don't but we
have no choice but to stand
I want to talk about the only thing I
wrote down that I wanted to talk about
was like Danielle's house situation yeah
and has she's having oliver co-sign the
two million dollar loan like what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] has he never seen the
show
also like wasn't she engaged to me
Duchess and now she's like having sex
with Maria and like jegi Oliver is the
Duchess guy I know
/ like why is she saying maybe show that
back together with Marty when like you
can go be Megan Markel in Sussex right
no she is now like into the idea of
having a two million dollar house in New
Jersey when she could also have like a
palace in Versailles and a private jet
why makes no sense she by the way and
you know what she is like such a monster
and she keeps getting the second amazing
guys and like she is one of those women
that you hear about who I was like a
magical judge know I know it's like in
the movie that I just made you watch
Bachelorette when isla Fisher he's like
have you heard of a magical vagina she
Jimmy all stabbed has a magical one um
what does that entail having a magical
John yeah I know I have no idea like I
just need to know this spell how she
gets people to like do whatever and
actually and I totally thought that she
was lying about having sex with Marty
but no she wasn't no she wasn't
I need like to take life lesson I need a
master class from Danielle Staub I'm
like how to have a magical vagina no
same because like honestly they could
that should be your next product because
it's clear that I'm never gonna make her
a full-time housewife like that's just
not in the cards for me like a life
coach even though next next episode I
think is a finale she and Margaret like
get into it physically yeah
but Margaret did start it but do nails
like it to another actually we're good
start of it yeah put a whole bottle of
water on her head yeah that's not okay
no well we'll judge when we see it and
then one more thing I want to talk about
which I didn't really like care for the
conversation being had at Jackie's house
with her dad but when I found to me the
most fascinating that I don't know if
anyone picked up on is when they were
playing the home videos and she was
getting into the car in a junior prom
you could see the cul-de-sac she grew up
on and it was literally mega mansions
like I've never seen such big houses in
my life no but it's also the same house
that her dad is in right now no it can't
be I'm pretty sure that it was it was
the same staircase outside like the same
situation also in that house is straight
out of the 70s that's true but I was
thinking like where did this picture up
because literally the cold exactly now
the pan I saw two houses that were mega
man really I didn't I my investigation
ended when she walked down the stairs
but that's when you're started yeah you
know I didn't notice how they might even
have been the same house but I guess
that would make like that couch if they
were sitting on in that
yeah 70 it's not a new house also like
I'm not one to judge you know other
people's situations but like it's kind
of odd their parents live in several
houses like if you want to be in the
same house and live in separate rooms
like I kind of get that but like summer
house it's like be honest call spade a
spade your divorce it's the honest truth
yeah I've been honestly if it works for
them yeah well and nothing else really
happened in the episode Margaret sat
down with Marty he found out they did in
fact have sex
Marty's like such a weirdo and the fact
that they can let all hang out when he
said such mean things about Margaret and
then like your husband's in the pool is
weird sort of but the way that Margaret
explains it like right after that
happened he called and apologized and
that's more than big nails ever done
thanks true I'm okay though TMZ Dallas
because that was like real a the meat
and potatoes of the whole night um
hearing things that I wrote down okay on
the count of three let's say me the star
of last night's episode was okay yeah
three two one court Wescott oh of course
it's ja the Wescott the Wescott okay
here i wrote down everything that i
thought he was so great at when he gave
great advice before the parties sitting
on the bed being like you have to tell
Cameron he was very eloquent I just
thought he was giving Cameron the best
advice for Cameron cuz that's the only
thing he cares about and I thought he
was like really sweet and not like a lot
of these husbands like brush off this
drama like no he was actually invested
then in the car when she was being
Cameron was being like so slow to get
out like the actual thing and he's like
that's not all that's not the whole
story
yeah come on love that and then he was
letting take the picture at the end like
I just oh my god he was so cute and when
he came over and got Cameron and was
like Rachel free whatever was great so
he's like there's no Rachel no by the
way and he's right like I jealous is
very society driven and Cameron is the
heart of the society and honestly like
Leon had a bad reputation before but not
be some of anything like really
substantial like now you have to go they
get away from really toxic
yeah and Cameron did like what she
needed to do she said her piece and she
really went toe to toe with Lana and she
was like I'm not scared of you you
should be scared of me and she didn't
mean that in the way like I'm gonna bite
you were hit you a man like I am
everything in this town and he had more
nothing right and like even though
sometimes I might act like simply
deference to you yep I am aware of how
it works yeah I thought she was very
headstrong and I know that was hard for
her and that really confirmed everything
that she's always said about herself
where it's like she pretends to be done
but she's actually smart and I don't
even think she pretends to be
that she's smarter than she seems but
it's like she sees yeah that's how
Cameron sees it another thing I wrote
down was that before they went to the
party Carrie and her husband went to
dinner and every time they sit down to
dinner I got a pan I'm like what are we
fighting about today what it was like
she had obviously never had this
conversation with him that she's been
telling the women and telling us in
confessionals because he said okay and
then they kissed like the whole
storyline code just ended the season if
they just had a conversation except they
still don't have a house no and when the
producer asked Carrie do you think
Yerger spend the rest of your life with
Eduardo and she gave the funniest answer
she's like not if he doesn't give me
what I want like honestly she's a boss
but like I don't know how you go back to
having a marriage like after you've said
that on the public television you know
yeah I don't it like I just I respect
people who are honest about their issues
and it's so easy to be like we're gonna
be together forever but that's not how
life works and I think because she's
been divorced she like sees that you
know and she's realistic and I Stan ya
know by the way love her like she has to
come back I absolutely adore her I
thought her husband's reaction to
finding out what LAN said about her was
absolutely hysterical calling her he
said remember the Alamo hilarious and
then let's get into and how was the name
of the episode Oh was it was a great
response yeah and then Cameron was like
what's the Alamo let's get into the
actual mean potatoes because Cameron was
wondering the potatoes you know what
it's um it's really the only pertinent
phrase yeah so Cameron starts the whole
thing she takes Leon down basically just
gave her a warning she was like I just
wanna let you know like what you said
was not okay and I told Kerry and I'm
glad that she did then that Leon didn't
get like Selleck Leon got to fully be
faced with her with her charges mhm
and then Kerry came over it was all like
a great day I thought it's almost like
it was planned by producer so you know
but yeah and then Kerry came over and I
thought Kerry was so poised and honestly
like if someone I had found that someone
like had said that about me even if I
didn't like the person like I would
probably start crying like just calling
me like a Jew Gio Gio Gio like it's
obviously derogatory like just state
someone's nationality when it's
completely irrelevant like it's
derogatory like no matter how you slice
it right and no and just ate someone's
nationality in a derogatory way right it
don't even if she said that Mexican like
that's still bad watching it over and
over
it just like which which you thing up
that they're all bad but which do you
think was the worst thing she said ooh
um I mean I guess chirping Mexican I
thought it was worse when she was in
that dark corridor with Stephanie and
she said herself of the face
come on Baskin you're all strong and
that was that's the most fun because
it's so cringy when Cameron was trying
to imitate lyric she also said that you
were being because she literally can't
recreate something so I'm times are old
like by the way that was a problem with
trying to tell everyone trying to tell
Carrie what Leon did because you can't
replicate it because she naturally say
stuff like it was her actions like
Anthony tried to say [ __ ] like she loves
herself in the face like it was just
it's actually hard to reiterate yeah
it's and it's hard to rewatch over and
over again I think all the women handled
it in a good way especially Carrie she's
so strong and like composed and and it
was like no matter what what was said in
Thailand I feel like there was like some
people are on Carrie sides Deandra Lee
Anne whatever it's like it's game over
like she completely crossed the line it
was so disrespectful and then her
reaction to it her first reaction was no
I deny her second reaction of own and
not apologized wasn't good
her third reaction of apologised but
like qualify the apology and still not
see how what you said was offensive it's
it's not good
no it was so bad and then she left and
they kind of positioned the the the
finale like all the women without her it
came in like Lisa Vanderpump vibes like
the vibe was so much better without her
when yeah when they just took that
picture yeah and you really feel like
they were setting it up for her not
being there next season and I honestly
don't think that they can I think that I
don't know what happens at the Reunion
I think that Bravo's gonna wait to see
what the fans yeah I think her time
maybe up yeah even though like just from
a straight like perspective of like the
show like Liam does every season like be
the center of the drama like I don't
know what we would actually do without
her but I do think like Bravo has to
take some sort of stand like that there
has to be a line in house why I was in
Atlanta it was drawn with Phaedra I do
think this has to be a line also um
Basin like what Leanne's been tweeting
or posting to Instagram it doesn't seem
like she's taking it very seriously well
that she's like sorry
so uh she
she's like obviously I'm not racist so
it doesn't bode well yeah I don't think
she has handles it well at the Reunion
yeah speaking of reunions we got the OC
reunion where like they acted like Vicki
was a secondary cast member I mean while
she's on for the whole thing right I
understood why she was getting fed up
and she was acting just like so entitled
she was hanging fruit to everyone who
she works with no no that is so not okay
like even no matter how you feel you're
annoyed whatever like this is your job
and if you can't just be so rude to
production like these are people they're
not like your slaves yeah she was being
so rude and it's even yelling at Andy
I'll be very upset like right before
they went live but out of control nuts
like that's not how a human being acts
and then kept saying this is my show my
show like Jew that any self-awareness
you're not even a full time cast member
anymore this is a literally more broad
win show than it is your show yeah she
[ __ ] hates Bronwyn even I watch
Ivan's life she cannot stop saying mean
things about her honestly the reunion
was just a mess 500 conversations going
on it wants Kelly and Tamara couldn't
stop fighting and then in the middle of
real conversations being at any dumb job
because they start off with the small
fights they build to the bigger fights
we'll get the Kelly
Shannon Tamara fight next week but it's
like until that is addressed it comes up
in every other fight it's almost like
they should just start with it but like
it's so true it's like silly because
they're there try to go clown logical
but they end up working backwards yeah
also like our girls Emily and Gina like
they were breaking my heart for a second
breaking my heart but I like that at the
end of the day like they love each other
they love each other and it's like that
it's a real friendship and I have a lot
of hope for them so like I was getting
really disheartened seeing like well I
guess that's where our friendship is
right now but then obviously she got up
again her hug like I thought it was
great this is what I wrote down
Bronwen looks so different do you notice
like I don't know what maybe she's only
parting her hair in the middle for the
first time but she looks like a
completely different kids a completely
new hair spot right now I love it it's
just like a sleek blowout I thought she
looks great me too I don't know why it
looked so different Emily had a walker
because she did get her hip surgery very
pertinent this week Walker's her and
Jeffrey Epstein I mean sorry Harvey
Weinstein
so Emily and Gina got into a fight again
about Vegas um I really just feel like
they both are are right and wrong in
every situation except for the cousin
thing like I will die on the hill of
like Gina's so out of control like
assuming the worst in Emily that she
would set her up on a date with someone
who had a girlfriend um I don't think
she assumed the worst I think it's like
you didn't even care to do the bare
minimum of research to find out the one
thing that this guy needs to have
in order to go on a date with me I feel
like that research is like hey want to
go on a date with my friend sure he
would have said no if he had a
girlfriend like that's just common
knowledge I guess it just puts Gina in
like a city situation when she's
terrible fragile terrible terrible to be
like I don't believe you like to assume
the worst like no but right but like
that was Tamara not believing Gina but
Tamara was getting a Gina Patti but also
yes and when Gina was upset about it she
didn't say anything to Emily which I
actually really when I'm mad at you I
don't want to talk to you like I don't
want to ask what happened I just want to
be mad right and until she talked her
and understood her side they couldn't
get over it
it was just like Emily and Gina's
friendship was already so fragile and
Emily went out and tried to do a nice
thing and I believe 100% she had good
intention like it just ended up being
like an another thing that like was
making more distance between them and
throwing Gina even more into Tamara's
arms which obviously made Emily insecure
like I felt really bad yeah and then the
last thing I wanted to discuss was this
Jane Roe lawsuit [ __ ] hilarious
hilarious Vicki's out of control and so
is Kelly um and I feel like all the
women on the couch like Kelly you're
being crazy but like no one is
addressing out Vicky was being just as
crazy as Kelly last night yeah oh so was
Kelly being that crazy everyone was
being walmart and Sam's Club was so
funny yeah that was yeah I don't even
[ __ ] know I I can't judge the Kelly
situation until it next week until I see
what's what
is this a two-part or a three-part
reunion I think three oh yeah Monday and
Thursday next week it's on that's so
weird that they're just like shoving
these episodes out like they can't wait
to get the season over yeah it is weird
very strange but then when we come back
we have Vanderpump rules Wow and Randall
Emmett's on the cast dead and they have
the wedding I wonder if I'll be in the
background like for a second oh my god
that would be so exciting
I'd say I hope not because I ended up
feeling so bad in that dress I'm sure
you look beautiful yeah I did um before
we wrap up I just want to say everything
we're thankful for this year and it
starts with why oh you yes what a great
year to be a toaster
what a great year to be a host of the
morning toast we can't thank you guys
enough for making this show what it is
we have had so much fun living the dream
like I can't believe that this is our
job and thank you guys for just
continuing to support the toast support
everything we do from the merch to the
patreon to live events we can't wait to
see you all at camp toast like this
ecosystem only exists because of the
people who are in it and that's you guys
so thank you for you and we like
and thank you for being just like a
positive light in the treacherous world
of 2019 hopefully 2020 is a little bit
brighter yeah that's all we could hope
for
that's all we can hope for I wouldn't
think everyone in our studio yeah and
being there productions that he's loved
you guys we want to thank everyone that
works on our show our do Bo do boom are
aging that what everyone is Barry Ben
Julia Marcos regular basis
um Thank You Claudia oh my god thank you
honestly thank you because as much as
2019 was the year of the toast like I
also feel like it was a year the dirty
jeans store where I got to like live my
dream and I only got to do that because
there was someone back here like holding
down the fort sitting through co-hosts
that were like a little rough taking
care of feel like you are literally like
my right arm like and I would die
without you in the show but not survivor
wasn't for the tenacity and the hard
work of one miss chocolate ass right
thank you guys I this is my dream job
there's nowhere else I'd rather be um
let's do a little quick resolution do
you have any resolutions no I found what
those resolutions got the lamest thing
ever except that we said early and
episodes like some things we wanted to
do better next you know I want to
control my temper and yeah I really feel
like I'm a perfect like I'm in love with
myself I think I'm so smart funny cool
and like who wouldn't want to be my
friends so honestly resolutions are for
broken people and I'm not broken I'm
totally getting it good for you for
trying to better yourself honestly I
just don't have enough time and I feel
like I'm good enough yeah you're
learning as you go like you're made
changes every day why it's only started
on January 1st right like that that's
for people who don't actually want to
make changes I've been making changes
every day also want to say big thank you
and that we love you to our teen and
Families ever-growing TNN family lots of
good things happening in tienen next
year yes there's new episodes of mood by
Lauren Elizabeth the snatchler date
night with Raven and Adam such good
stuff I have to listen to this week's
mood with where I'm Elizabeth because I
hear we're spoken about we are we are in
check she said she gives us like a
really nice like moment I'm so excited
we take you to it and that's all she
wrote my sweaters obviously from shot
morning toast calm I think this is the
my favorite outfit I've ever worn I wish
it was Christmas because I'm ready to
just know so you're a Rockette no I'm
ready to go down to Radio City and also
if you are missing us head over to
patreon.com slash to Maureen toast
because starting tomorrow and every
other for the next five work days at
10:00
there will be new podcast episodes of
Claudie and i really going through
everything so there's so much stuff I
feel like we stuff like you and I we've
done five podcast this week and it's
just I know everything about you sis
right and it's like there's so much we
talked about this week that we didn't
talk about in this show so it's like
we're referencing stuff totally so if
you miss us patreon.com such a morning
toast also a great gift to give shot
morning toast com4 great gifts stocking
stuffers stockings themselves and for
the last time in 2019 thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to give this
video a thumbs up subscribe and write a
comment about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we are also available as a
podcast pretty much anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's iTunes Spotify
skit your Public Radio I already know
cashbox so wherever you listen to
podcast please subscribe give us a five
star review and feel free to leave a
review about like I don't know how
genius we are and how this show is
literally the greatest thing since
sliced bread it's up to you to take
creative control we love you guys so
much have an amazing new year happy
holidays don't drink and drive and try
not to kill your families while you see
them for Christmas bye feel like you're
going to you just put on an episode of
the morning toast
you